we got some new merch made but it's only
exclusive for our petrie honors
so if you go on our patreon we got some
new tiers we got the coffee mug tear
and the hoodie tier and if you're
defibrillator you get
both so make sure you go to patreon
check that out and thank you guys so
much for supporting and enjoy the video
[Music]
what is the most polite country
you've ever been to denmark denmark oh
an urban and denmark i want to like
japan
let's play yeah i did japan yeah i would
say japan or norway
norway's very plate i remember that you
went um
you went dog sledding right we talked
yeah cause okay
after that i i just wanted to go dogs
that was actually finland lapland
oh okay okay very polite there too and
yeah you changed my perception on
dog sledding and all that because you
think it was abuse
yeah i really did and you like said it
was very humane
and like they actually need it because
they have they're like super working
dogs
oh i see it's like they got adhd
and they want to run yeah that makes
sense that makes sense
wait he loves dog voting just saying i
love dogs
he's a big dog guys that's why i don't
have none is this like a
most uh polite country in the world
survey
i wish it was but it's not in fact it's
actually about specifically japan
can i win losers for yulin
that's china china what's that the dog
festival
oh no no no you eat the dogs no yeah
china is far from the nicest country
in the world i would say um i heard the
country
side is nice i just never went there
never been
i don't know i only read the news uh in
japan though
they recently went viral the police uh
force went viral
uh for a very weird interaction with
a leftist group in japan so i don't know
what a leftist group
means per se but in their world it seems
like they were
criminal and this leftist group was
involved with like a riot that happened
in the 70s
which is 50 years ago so i'm not quite
sure
what's going on with it it might be a
serious communist group because there
was a time
what leftist means yeah basically but
there there was a time when north korea
was funding pro-communist groups
in japan to try and shift it toward
their way
yeah and i think maybe russia or just
other countries had involvement in that
so
at the time the cold war was happening
all over the world
japan you know because it's an ally of
the west and all that stuff
and and yadda yadda like they that's how
they were trying to infiltrate
so if this was happening in the 60s or
70s i think that's
time appropriate for that phenomenon
that was going on so there were
terrorist groups in japan actually
and what ended up happening is like they
were um
they were like they were what do you
call it like hostage situations there
were like
certain like building government
building takeovers and things like that
so that's not very polite uh that is not
very polite well sometimes you burp a
little bit
it's more about the interaction that
these the the police have the hostage
situation was probably like
please please can you go over here oh
that's very bad that's not too far off
uh so or else i kill you a little yeah
so a little bit more backstory so the 83
year old leader of this group
takeo shimizu he recently made
a speech at a tokyo rally and that was
his first appearance
in 51 years so since the 70s and so i
guess that's the reason why now the
police are back on his trail
and they uh recently got a tip that one
of its members
uh made a driver's license under with a
false address or something so that was
the way they traced it back to this
particular warehouse and this video
shows you
what went down when they went to go make
an arrest or whatever they're trying to
do here
all right so this is polite polite
japanese police
are people just recording it like news
media or something so they're trying to
they're trying to stop through the door
and they're like what the [ __ ] hey you
don't have to sell my door dude
like hey we could just walk through here
you can just use the door hey
oh my god i like how you push the police
they forced the police to temperature
checks for coven
that's so funny that's so crazy that is
hysterical
and that is the japanese police right
dude the japanese police is so nice
why can't they be that nice around the
cove that's crazy
what's the cove you guys don't remember
the cove uh-uh the dolphin thing
oh what are you doing oh [ __ ] too real
man i don't know
i'm just like what [ __ ] oh that
documentary
i haven't seen it what were the japanese
police like in that one
well it's not the direction yeah no no
no no it's the government
and like was it an australian uh
documentarian guy or i don't know
i don't know anyways based off of that
it's just a uh it's just a little town
and they're an old school like fishing
village and then they have this
tradition
where they heard dolphins into the cove
and then they kill them
and then they kill so many that the
ocean water is just
okay red yeah don't watch the dock if
you have a good time
don't watch the dog but it's like the
yulin dog festival where it's not like
japan it's just this little town's
tradition
right so it's not really reflective of
japan as well right yeah it's just that
area yeah would you say this is the
representation of japan as a whole enjoy
i've seen some
funny [ __ ] like that dude it's [ __ ]
hilarious but some stuff is pretty
uh wow like it's it's so bipolar
like they'll have cute little uh police
cars that look like it's for kids
and it's very non-threatening the whole
culture i think is built around like
not being scary i guess
and then um i think it's all because of
the whole military
uh weird [ __ ] that they did during world
war ii so they want to be far away from
that at least
so like oh we're not crazy and dangerous
so the cops come up with clown houses
like
i'm sorry i have to talk to you right
now i'm in a box
and i think that there might be a little
element of like
protecting the kids like the like not
scaring them
to make everything more kid-friendly
looking because there's a lot of [ __ ]
kids out on the streets too
so like if you've noticed like when we
go there right there's like
six-year-olds and five-year-olds by
themselves yeah
and then there's everywhere access to
them so like
if they're in society you don't want to
scare them or whatever but there's all
these different
reasons for that but i've seen um so
remember um
in the the the the shinjuku area the
entertainment area right
i remember walking around with my mom
and then there was
um these cops marching down
like military dudes and then they're
just pushing people out of the way
like they were going somewhere and then
they all lined up
behind the building and then they
started grabbing up all of these mafia
guys
oh snap yeah that's wild yeah and then
they were just
uh covering their heads and then the
media guys came and started taking
pictures
and they they that that that was a
pretty like
well it looked like some gustavo [ __ ]
like that's a far cry from what we do
yeah this is comical like the the
internet this went viral and the
internet is basically
like japan stay you you know because
like the rest of the world seems to be
on fire you know and like and like
especially in the states
you don't you don't go walk up to a
coffin hey use the [ __ ] door you know
who's the
who are the people taking the
temperatures are the gangsters they're
they're they're they're staff members of
this
organization and they're forcing the
cops before you come in here and arrest
us i gotta check the guy's temperature
exactly i know you have a warrant but
let me check your temperature first i
like how the cops are like oh okay yeah
yeah our costs would be like they put
you on the ground already
exactly the cops there too look like you
can
beat their ass do you feel like there's
like a strong
air of discipline there though where
there's something underneath that where
like you don't want to mess around in
japan
because somebody at the top is gonna
mess you up
so the guys that you see in public like
they're more like the tsa guys
and when serious things go down there
are the swat guys
so like there's footage you can find
this right there was this one guy
he was drunk he was an american dude six
foot something
he was belligerent and then um
then you see the real japanese cops that
come out and they just
they don't have guns out there so they
do everything with hand oh
and they were just chasing this guy
around and then one guy tackled him and
he's like a five foot dude
and then the other guys just at piled on
him and they just did some jiu jitsu
stuff and had him in a choke
so like a lot of this stuff happened
which shortcuts were trained like that
old true they don't have any
people with guns that'll shoot at them
yeah so true
different oh yeah you know what the gun
thing is actually a really big
difference that america has to face
compared to all
other countries it seems like most
countries don't have that same issue
with guns and even culture in general
too
like oh i think in a lot of asian
culture obedience is like one of the top
things so it's like yeah so even if
you're wrong you're just like that's
authority i'm obey for now
you know versus here it's like if you
feel you're been wrong you're gonna
stand up for 100
so it just creates more recipes for
conflict i couldn't believe just walking
around tokyo
the floors are clean enough to eat off
of yeah which is crazy it's like
everyone obeys the rules yeah have you
been to singapore
no same [ __ ] really yeah but you're like
not only would i eat off of it i would
[ __ ] deliver a baby here
really yeah that's draconian there
though like no it's the reason why it's
like that what does draconian mean
like like super scary punishment
like in japan it's not because it's
draconian so for example like in
singapore right like if you spit gum on
the floor you get caned or whatever
right right okay
yeah i mean if you get caught with
marijuana you're like in jail for
yeah 10 30. if you get caught blowing a
dude you're in going to jail too
if you're a guy but in japan though if
you litter or whatever you don't
you don't get beat for it you know it's
not the same
but i didn't know that stopping dudes
from blowing dudes in public would make
the streets so clean
or i'd have been before that here too i
think that's what i think what are you
talking about i'm not gonna touch that
one i'm not gonna touch that one
there are funny videos though or like
really cool videos of this stuff going
down
there's fist fights too with like
citizens and cops and stuff
um yeah i just went down a rabbit hole
of all this stuff in japan specifically
japanese you know a lot about japanese
cops
yeah i don't know i just went down the
it was funny yeah
was super cop a japanese copper chinese
cup bad concoct
hong kong cop and then super copy
actually teams up with
chinese chinese government cops and
stuff like that yeah
yeah you got to know your asian [ __ ] to
understand that movie
to its fullest i haven't watched it in
25 years they have really cute outfits
they do they're like little trousers
with
galoshes you know they're like oh come
on we don't look threatening it looks
like slightly british
yeah and then they kind of like slouch a
little bit which yeah like
they're not very like i don't know it's
great
that's great why does singapore hate the
gays do we know they do
yeah oh i didn't know that i don't know
about singapore but
uh having been to malaysia malaysia is
uh
there's like muslim uh like uh
community and stuff and even the
government has like like that's a
national religion right
i think so yeah and even the government
has like muslim like laws built into it
or something
like that and so with with like just
you know conduct like conduct and stuff
it's very
conservative i would say yeah like you
can't hug like men
can't hug women um and then we did like
uh we had like a live event out there
and then the the people like the people
watching
um they had to be split up with men's
section and women's section like they
couldn't co-mingle yeah and the reason
why i bring up malaysia is because
they're like
literally side by side to each other
where was that very close
it's the chinese immigrants in malaysia
that felt like second citizens
they they took over singapore says this
is ours yes and i
was in singapore teaching young students
how to
like write movies and [ __ ] and uh i
remember them telling me like don't say
anything against the government and i
was like
i can't say like the government sucks or
anything here and they're like no you
can't say that to me like
you want to go to jail yeah exactly i
think that's just how they roll
in southeast asia a lot of countries are
like that actually
americans are very lucky to be doing the
[ __ ] that we do right now so i hope that
singaporean government
is what i'm trying to say i hope
singaporean government looks up
everybody who worked with me in that
filmmaking class and they all
interrogate and then make sure to make
sure that they're all down with
like what singapore wants oh man that's
super democratic steve yeah that's
what i'm hoping for you know a man of
people
[Music]
you